first of all thank you all for coming
it's great to see you guys here my name
is Derrick Sakamoto I'm a senior user
interface designer on hearthstone and
I'm here to talk to you about how we
went about creating an immersive user
experience really quick bio my been a
blizzard for a little over 12 years now
my first job was on world of warcraft
designing the UI for that I worked on
vanilla - Wrath of the Lich King and
after six plus years of that it was time
for a change for me so I was fortunate
to be able to move on to team Pegasus
which in turn became hearthstone yay so
for the next 30 minutes I'm gonna talked
about talk to you about some of the
high-level ideas and principles that
guided us to get hearthstone where it is
today in terms of UI and game so number
one is finding your seed let's get
physical and UI gets to sit at the big
kids table so finding your seed what am
I talking about to me the seed is like a
muse or like a it's like an image or a
movie or song something for your team
that they can all look at and understand
the direction that your game is gonna go
in so before I show you our seed I'll
show you what it hearthstone was like
before we had a core idea to work from
and there's a warning people outside of
team five have not seen these images and
maybe a lot of people on team five have
not seen these images just because the
team is growing so I introduced you
Warcraft legends this is a build called
Fire and Ice and this was the build that
got us greenlit and I think at this time
we had maybe the rogue in the mage and
that warlock was still work in progress
but clearly this is not what we wanted
you know for for hearthstone another
idea we had was having a world map where
you unlock you travel across gather all
Ezzor off unlocking regions and zones
doing single-player quests and and
content to unlock them and this is
actually a screenshot of our flash
prototype we created the whole game in
flash first and this was all working we
had adventures that worked seeing a
player
and those were all done by then rode I
think and here we go this is a pre-alpha
visual target for our game and I think
everyone's pretty happy that we didn't
hit this target it just has no life
it looks like Tron and there's a super
complicated right this is this is not
what we wanted for ourselves and there's
a bunch of other stuff that we did you
know for single-player there's books
there's crazy weird 3d cards there's
hologram cards I'm just glad I have a
job after this stinker
hearthstone the forest you know this
mock-up had me stumped mad yeah and this
was matchmaking and then this is a real
gem we knew that when we were doing our
matchmaking we didn't want to have a
screen with a counter going up you know
just County you start searching for
players or whatever so what kind of went
too far the other way and this is what
we ended up with zero my fire beeper
match the force fight right pretty
awesome right so let the record show
that the path to hearthstone as it is
today was not obvious or clear to us so
this is why you need a seed the
otherwise are just running around in the
bushes right you just on the weeds doing
whatever and this video was created by
one over three yards and it was a result
of a super long meeting between me and
the artists just trying to figure out
what what could we do you know what
would what would be our division and so
here's this box you know you zoom into
it there's a world map there's zones to
choose from you choose your hero and it
rips open the map you zoom down into
this crazy world where people are
battling alright it makes it feel like
it's alive there's other people there
with you until you find your match BAM
like that and then you zoom out and then
you're on the game board and that's not
really hearthstone is kind of
hearthstone today but um I think this
really gave us something to latch on to
like this could be something you know
this is pretty neat
and so that's why you need to find your
seat and once this boss was kind of box
ID was established
I grew roots into the team into the
teams of minds and hearts and a goose
strengthen was able to grow up into this
beat into this tree and it branched out
and created all kinds of different
fruits which I'm about to show you so
this is our box if you haven't seen it
if you haven't played our game and once
we had that we had a framework for what
we wanted to do with our UI you know it
feels like maybe a jewelry box or a
music box or something and it came
became more obvious about how this stuff
was gonna work we want a little trays
and little things like keys that would
kind of fit in that environment now came
up with the making an idea for making
lame loading screens like tightening
hinges and that kind of stuff and then
once we had this box
it was always sitting on the table and
we were kind of one day we got to
thinking where is this table you know
and we decided well maybe it's in an inn
or a tavern and that's something like
that and once we'd have that idea it
kind of just created another like burst
of creativity so this is like our splash
screen for mobile this is a loading
screen it's like you're walking into the
tower and pushing up none of the doors
and there's a really warm inviting glow
coming in except for when you know the
servers are fold and it's like a sign
outside
it's like tables full but that was
pretty cool and then here's the key art
and we informed the key art you know but
in turn the the artist who did this
really fleshed out the world in the
context of playing hearthstone in the
world of warcraft and it really got us
excited cuz that's that's cool right and
this is something was really awesome
like this seed was strong enough that we
were able to give it to a third party
and they were able to fully realize that
tavern as the Blizzcon final stage and
that thing is incredible and we're still
trying to figure out how we can shop it
at little pieces and get in the office
but so far so far no dice this doesn't
really have anything to do with anything
except that a lot of us either worked on
WoW or big well fans and our game is
inspired by Wow and then kind of went
full circle and now it's inside of WoW
which is really cool to us so the
obvious question having a seat that's
awesome right that's great but how do
you find one you know that's that's a
real that's a real question and having
done so
I have no idea I mean but I can't tell
you kind of how we went about searching
for this in the beginning we started out
with this really awful flat parchment
garbage and we then we decided well this
game should probably be 3d and we want
it to be more physical as a side note
this mock-up was called Simon Says I
think I don't know and then we knew we
wanted more magic as well and then on
top of that we wanted to layer some
charm which is kind of one of our things
and finally we kind of said well just
really make it feel valuable and feel
constructed and this is kind of where we
ended up so find your seed the path to
your seed is never direct unless you're
super lucky or a super genius or
something but which we're neither you
should actively look for early in your
project just because it'll make the rest
of things go so much smoother because it
just makes everything better it makes
everything fit fit and feel like it's
one thing and I think I think you must
find it if if you want to have a shot
and may haven't your game be something
special have it have a true vision I
think you need to find it ok section two
let's get physical' what the heck does
this mean into development we had been
doing 3d UI and I took a step back and
was thinking about what the trends were
in UI development at the time it looks
like everything is moving to flat UI
design you know everything is really
slick and really smooth and just
completely 2d I mean I was completely
maybe 2 toned or something like that and
once we really started thinking about it
and thinking about what was right for
our project we kind of just embraced it
we're like do this get physical
you know physicality is can be big for
us and I have no idea if this age range
is right or not but so this idea of
physicality really started to
traceroutes through all of our project
and influenced things in expected ways
and some unexpected ways so it makes
things feel valuable you know these are
objects people can relate to the
materials people can know whether
they're or something or not because
there's
holding gems and these kind of things
and it's important for us because as a
free-to-play game we really want to
respect you know players time and money
that they spend and given things that
feel really good and being a card
clicking game so a lot of us as we had
reflected cards as kids and there's
something about opening a pack of cards
right there's the crinkle the foil
there's the smell when you open it and
we kind of used the tools we have with
your visuals and sound to try to
replicate that joyous of an experience
and you know something that cool another
thing is that this physicality um
unifies the experience I'm going to show
you a couple screens
oops this is like our announcement
screen for an X ramus this is just our
matchmaking spinner and then this is our
store so you're selecting cars and the
storm is around and these are all
different UIs they live in different
planes but I think having them all be
physical and move in the same similar
way it's like there's a lot of bounce
going on there's a lot of over-rotation
kind of things makes them feel cohesive
whether the player realizes it or not
here's an unexpected semi unexpected one
it's a happy accident with touch and
that hearthstone was supposed to be the
main platform was desktop and it would
be nice and we got it to tablets but it
was not a sure thing by any means and so
when we designed things like the cards
they would tilt as you drag them around
and they swoosh and when you tap the
board like dust flies up all this kind
of stuff
once we translated it to touch it was
like a little bit magical to me anyways
and for me that's the best way to play
the game is with your finger actually
moving around these pieces and it feels
like you're part of that world this is
kind of a selfish one it's it's fun to
work on this stuff a couple of us like
to make things like when we got whittles
I like to do some woodworking on the
side another guy is into like
world war ii stuff where it's old and
you can just feel the construction of it
and for us to be a geek out on that
while we're building the stuff is really
fun and this is kind of a big one as a
kart collectible card game you you
really need to have this go version over
the shoulder pew appeal which is that
someone's walking by to see your game
being played you know they need to be
interested in be like oh maybe that's
cool maybe that's something I should try
as opposed to you know it's like this
tomandjerry stuff but as opposed to
being seeing all these words and numbers
and just being kind of turned off by the
whole thing upfront without really
getting it give me a chance this one is
also in for selfish reasons these are a
click more clickable these are things to
fidget with while you're playing the
game our 3d guys do crazy job on these
things
and I included this particular one
because my two-year-old almost every
night asked me to play hearthstone and
what he means by that is load up this
board and launch that rocket ship so
that's why that's in there so another
cool unexpected thing is that fans have
embraced it you know once if you design
these things to be physical it's kind of
not a big leap to see that they could be
brought into the real world and I think
fans are really starting to connect with
it and once they build these things it
really jazzes us up and you know gives
us it makes us excited because these are
things we designed but people are
actually realizing these things for
themselves so we have cakes you know we
have wooden boxes we have this thing
which I mean it's a play piece but it's
cool that he was excited to make it
let's just say that wallets and then
this cake really takes the cake if you
know what I mean like I want one of
these at my birthday and and this is the
holy grail right this is the box and I
think everybody wants one of these
things these things awesome so this
image is terrible
terrifying I included it because our
because Ben Brode hates it it makes them
feel really lucky so taking a stance on
physical UI you know doing this it's not
all roses there's definite downsides to
doing it
but I think if you are aware of the
downsides and you have answers and and
reasons for why they're okay I think
it's a it's it's good to do these things
so number one it's hard to expand on the
left side of that screen there's our
nine heroes and it's like what happens
if we had another one
I don't know right but our stance on
this is that it's finely crafted
everything has its place and we tend to
design for now and what that means is we
have tight deadlines we gotta we can't
you know try to foresee everything in
the future and make it expandable in all
different ways that may or may not
happen so we designed for now and that's
why things try to we try to make things
have their own little homes and we do
have this tradition on the team of
screwing over or future selves we say oh
what about this thing well future Derek
will figure it out he'll be smarter by
then right
and obviously this time comes around and
we go dang you pastor you're such a jerk
like and I have this all the time we're
just always cursing our past selves
another downside is that it's very
research resource intensive to create
this is our just art collection manager
this is like two years of my life which
is awesome
but these are all the things that we go
through to try to get to where we are
you know and it may not seem obvious
when you look at it but it's a tough
road to get there and the argument to
this is that our game is you i we don't
have huge virtual worlds and monsters
running around all we have is our board
and we have the box so it's it makes
sense for us to invest our resources and
doing this this is a big knock against
us this is this screenshots from reddit
we look at reddit a lot and are sad
sometimes but this issue is not the most
efficient navigation and so for this
example it takes a ton of clicks to do
something that maybe should be a lot
more straightforward and our answer to
this is that we generally design for
flavor over efficiency we designed this
box to fold open the drawers to slide
around all for you to have a sense of
place of where you are in this box you
can't instantly jump from place to
because we feel that that kind of
disconnects you from the experience
however when things are this bad this is
gonna even get worse when we go to to
phone because some of these screens need
to be moved into separate to separate
screens we realize this is a real
problem we need to solve so this is
something we're looking at and so it's
nice to have a point of view but once
things start affecting the player I mean
we have this in the middle of our campus
engraved in bronze gameplay first so
this is that there's definitely times
when you need to make compromises this
is a future issue maintaining across
multiple platforms we have desktop
tablet and phone in the future and I
mean desktop and tablet that are pretty
similar which is good but phone is a
complete complete overhaul so moving
forward is gonna be challenging I think
but from a company perspective it's
worth it you know it's been taken step
back if we can get tracked in the mobile
space because it's someplace that we
should probably be going
so let's get physical physical you as on
UI is awesome in the right context there
are significant cost of doing it it's
great for touch devices and if this
thing if physicality is not the thing
for you you should find that trait that
you know most informs of games and
really run with it to its full potential
because you'll get a lot of good results
out of it that's my final point which is
you I get to sit at the big kids table
and what I mean by this is that this is
not true of every project but I've seen
it where designers come up with a game
they come open mechanics and then
they're like this slappa you ient on
this thing right and the other aspect of
that is I've seen UI be kind of a
second-class citizen in terms of
production right maybe they get a
dedicated programmer maybe not or maybe
a dedicated artist and so these are some
issues that I think we tried to address
so we didn't want to be off in the
corner you know eating chicken fingers
and hotdogs and spilling milk on
ourselves and crying or whatever we
wanted to be at the big kids table
and so it's a testament to our
leadership I think that UI design was
given a fair shake and was given a you
know parity with game design
and one way this works is that sometimes
design would you have this very loose
design let me maybe a couple sentences
and we start doing mock-ups and then
design would come and be informed by
those mock-ups and it was kind of like a
canary in the coalmine situation where
if the you I was super complicated
looking again maybe design needed to
take a step back and see what design was
causing those those complications and
maybe removing those or mitigating those
problems so here's just an example
here's our play screen we used to have a
ton of text on this describing the play
mode describing the hero class and their
power and all these numbers and we just
got rid of it all because nobody reads
right we know this and also we didn't
want this screen to be too scary to just
frighten people off before they you know
actually play the game and they would
learn all these details through playing
the game which is what we want in this
case we had designed a board and we had
the main use that we liked but only
seven fit so we're like well maybe we'll
just shrink him down as you start adding
him and I think we all decided that this
was not a good idea because it would
mess with the physicality of our stuff
when you see things zooming bigger and
smaller it's subtle but it affects your
perception of the value of these things
I think and having just a seven minion
limit is an interesting play mechanic I
think our decks used to be 60 cards and
that would mean that the area on the
right would scroll three whole pages
worth and that's like really hard to
keep in your mind at any given time and
it was a deal breaker for new players
for sure
and we saw we just reduced the deck size
to 30 and even that is quite formidable
to new players so we're working on
trying to ease that transition as well
this is a pretty old mechanic the priest
hero power used to give the next menu
plate plus one attack and plus one
health and so we need to show that on
the board and clearly it clutters up the
board with more numbers and it
encroaches into the minion space so the
here of power was changed
bidding that's an example of pushback
and so the he's the priest just heals
too from anything and this is very old
but this is a concept of the chain
we're an idea we're in card games you
play a card that your opponent can play
a card in response to that card and then
you can say no no I want to play a card
in response to that card and you can see
this gets really complicated visually
and so it was on the chopping block and
that from design standpoint it really
just bogged the game down and wasn't
cool so it's gone that was a design
aspect of it and here's the UI pipeline
the game pipeline version of it where we
have access to the same resources as you
know the full game because we kind of
are the game so here I am the singular
genius right this is this is our team
around 2012
I'm just toiling away in obscurity
obviously but that's clearly that's not
the case it's it's a real team effort I
mean a third of our team you know we
have a design director art director or
3d guy designer and tech artists all
kind of like working together on UI and
as we expanded recently we got a lot
bigger now we doubled our UI design
department which is we got another guy
and and that's maksimov over there and
he is doing the phone transition report
for us and then so now we have even more
firepower it's crazy what we can do with
its team like this and so we're getting
to see the players I wanted to show you
what it what it looks like to take a
feature from beginning to end and who's
involved with each step so here's UI
design this is a version of our wire
framing this is about as wire framing as
we get we don't use Visio or anything
like that it's all back of the napkin
stuff so this is UI just UI design and
then programming if we think there's
some issue that might come up with our
initial sketches and now we're just
iterating with UI design and 2d and then
at this point once design feels like we
have the requirements in our mock-up
like the may look good but at least
they're there then they usually drop out
of the discussion and we just kind of
wheedle away trying to figure things out
once we get to a point where we think we
have a good idea we bring in 3d to look
at it and say is this reasonable well
these things actually work being modeled
out and will they be able to slide under
each other and all this kind of stuff
and then here you'll notice there's a
big change between these two
and this is part of our design process
we're in the middle of mock-ups design
I'll find out oh wait you'd show rewards
or we need to have keys that open and
close these things or something like
that so that's why that that mock-up
changed so drastically
and this is when 3d and programming are
coming in to really start doing
production on it and then here's the
final deal this is what it looks like
modeled and then we bring on tech art to
do effects and programming so this is it
in motion
yeah so that's everybody's all working
in concert and I think the results are
kind of cool
so that's how the sausage made to recap
yeah so find your seeds you know it'll
make your project better and it'll save
you a lot of work in the long run
physical you guys are awesome in the
right context and good things will
happen if UI is appear to the rest of
development I guarantee it
so that's all I have to say I'd like to
leave you with a little bit of our
culture
so thank you all for coming I hope you
have a great GC and I don't know if we
have time for questions or comments
yes so I'm just kind of curious this
Blizzard plan on like kind of releasing
any tools to the unity community trying
to get back to community because
obviously their success with her stone
do I need to repeat the question or is
it okay there are currently no plans to
allow like mod ability or anything like
that
like kind of what we did on on WoW just
because of our audience and hopefully
we're trying to make you know a really
tight experience for players that's
really highly designed go for it how
long did it take to find the seed and
how many people were working on the
project up until that time it's hard to
say but I think it was this definitely
left less than ten and it probably took
it's hard to say cuz we're also bringing
people on but maybe a year or so
something like that along the lines of
how UI design was influencing game
design I'm wondering if there's been
hearthstone UI design influencing Wow UI
design like perhaps with the garrisons
or something along those lines are you
cross pollinating we definitely have a
UI group that means together and but
there is no explicit cross-pollination
but I think people in the company are
starting to look at this style and
saying that maybe there's something
there that we can bring into other games
that's for sure yeah you mentioned with
the Emax ramas where you had to change
your mock-ups to add like the keys and
the rewards were there any other points
where things really change the way that
you had to approach it because of some
element or was it more in the direction
of where you could change the priest
hero power because the you I needed it
to change it kind of there's examples of
both I can't think of any of the top of
my head but definitely there's
situations where we just had you know
this was the mechanic so we have to deal
with that you know Mike I can't think of
any of the top of my head but definitely
their sides where you know we have to
compromise or design compromise thank
you
we all know that a hearthstone have a
lot of the brilliant visual effects
there in the games but I feel that when
we move that to the mobile platform so
are constrained by the
power of the mobile device there is a
great decrease on the frame rate so how
did you make the decisions between the
trade-off of a great brilliant awesome
effect with a very smooth frame right to
guarantee the experience thank you this
is more of a question for engineers but
I mean do you sacrifice some of the
efest there no we don't intentionally
sacrifice any effect we design the
coolest effects that we can make and
then smart guys figure out how to
optimize that okay thank you so
successful card game usually create a
lot of opportunities for illustrators
for doing all these car illustrations
and I want to know like where
hearthstone team find out illustrations
for their card to reuse existing art and
resource from the police' library are
they actually hired and given
Commission's to other glass reader
created your card it's actually all of
those things we have a pool of existing
art which we use and then if there's
things not there then we'll commission
either extra artists or we have internal
artists who will handle those things so
there's our art director right there
yeah so it's all those things so I'm
another UI designer so it's cool to hear
the big table comment when you when you
guys were early on in the process what
what kind of or did you make any
argument about the validity of the UI
design and that hey this is as important
as the game design
you had mentioned like you guys don't
have a big world you know it's all UI
stuff mm-hmm did you make that argument
do you show like data analytics or so I
was very fortunate in that I had worked
with a design director for a number of
years on world of warcraft and that
experience made us really think hard
about you guys role in game design and
so I think we came to an agreement
together on that I did not have to sell
you know somebody on this idea that
that's the case but
I think you can look at any kind of
bored bored game type translation those
that you can make that argument like
this game is UI you know it's important
and and maybe hopefully maybe
hearthstone could be an example of that
I don't know you know I would like to
think that it could be the case during
the creation and designing the UI how
much we looked down with the overall
gameplay design
pardon me how much how much how much we
locked down already with play design we
were locked down and the fact that it
wasn't going to be a card game okay
nothing yes I was progressing yes
they're progressing at the same at the
same time and they're in that like I
said kind of they were informing each
other what this could be you know once
we started getting into this physical
space then the design started think
differently about you know how things
work
one more question how much time do you
expect the creation of the hearthstone
UI for phones to take and do you have
any plan to release date this choir next
one um soon next couple months is what I
can say um it's it's pretty far along
and it's looking pretty awesome so okay
thanks okay I think of that one more
okay yeah I noticed that you be now
still new comes pretty make anything
during news over here turn yes I wonder
if this was like a very game design
decision know if it was like you
explained before also some things that
was driven by the UI design this is not
it was semi UI but it's really the
designers who didn't like that flow of
play because you have to pay attention a
lot you know you have to be and so it
just felt like it wasn't a good flow for
us I think
and once we switch to the idea of these
maybe secrets that could George end of
the play something like that it just
made it like - my turn is my turn
you know I'm trying to solve a
single-player puzzle and I think that is
kind of the appeal of the game and we
get more expert
took you this long to get this question
I have to ask its we know it's an issue
and we are looking at it yes that's not
like a hand wave the answer it's it was
really something that's on our radar
okay that about does it
thank you so much